[Applaudissements]
la personne à côté de vous les amis
nouvel épisode de amour gloire et des
huit qui suis un petit peu à la guerre
qui fait rage bien sûr dans les
coulisses de tpm p vous allez encore
pouvoir juger le talent de comédien
d'une personne de l'équipe regarde là
[Musique]
cyril décidément tu es tellement
charismatique que même en peinture j'ai
l'impression que tu on regarde me suis
justement sert il a reçu un bouquet de
fleurs leur senteur me rappelle l'odeur
du souk
quand j'étais parti en tant que médecin
bénévole à casablanca à l'espagne mais
qui a bien pu lui adresser ce bouquet
tirer voici quelques fleurs pour te
témoigner mon amour signé un chroniqueur
qui préfère rester anonyme
ps en 1 10 je te joins une photo de moi
prise à l'improviste
cette lettre est décidément
bouleversante
mais qui cela peut-il bien-être
camille newman
en effet valérie bella smith comment va
patoche depuis son dramatique accident
de bobsleigh
mieux même s'il a toujours du mal à
regarder un star game mais que puis-je
pour toi tu peux tout dire ici rien est
enregistrée voilà je suis dans
l'embarras je souhaiterais que cyril
m'accorde un week-end de repos avec
patoche pour me ressourcer dans l'eau
mais les soldes mais j'en ai par le
patron d'edf
il ne veut rien dire tant parce qu'il
est têtu non parce qu'il est sourd et
bien valérie je ne peux rien pour toi
comment
puisque tu le prends comme ça il va
falloir que je t'avoue que camille
va-t-il apprendre à valérie que patoche
et lionel jospin sont la même et unique
personne pour cela ne ratez pas le
prochain épisode
[Applaudissements]
dans la poule à poules avec olivier
baroux philippe lellouche à laury
thilleman à fabien frantz gaston binet
ouazzani également debout si un bébé
il est là il est en prime time sur ses
droits de la chaîne il était comme ça ça
va merci michel perdu dans la bataille
est ouverte aériennes menées récemment
dans la stagiaire et